>>> WITH THE HOUSE ADJOURNED FOR
THE EVENING AND 11 FORMAL
EMBARRASSING REJECTIONS IN HIS
ATTEMPT TO BE SPEAKER NOW UNDER
HIS BELT, KEVIN McCARTHY HAS
JUST WEIGHED IN.
HE SPOKE WITH OUR OWN MANU RAJU
WHO JOINS US TONIGHT.
>> YEAH, WE JUST SPOKE TO KEVIN
McCARTHY, TALKING TO HIM ABOUT
THIS HISTORIC AND UNPRECEDENTED
IN MODERN TIMES SPEAKER VOTE
GOING TO -- FAILING ON 11
STRAIGHT TIMES.
HE STILL IS MAINTAINING THE
POSITION THAT HE WILL BE ELECTED
SPEAKER.
HE SAYS HE HAS NO TIME FRAME FOR
THAT.
HE ALSO DEFENDED THE CONCESSIONS
THAT HE HAS MADE TO THE FAR
RIGHT OF HIS CONFERENCE.
HE CAN PIN IT.
HE WILL NOT BE A WEAKER SPEAKER
BECAUSE OF THEM, AND I ASKED HIM
WHY DIDN'T YOU GET THIS RESOLVED
BY THE JANUARY 3rd WHEN THIS
BEGAN.
HE SAID THEY TRIED TO BUT
WEREN'T ABLE TO.
I ASKED HIM WHETHER THIS WOULD
BE RESOLVED BY TOMORROW?
HE DIDN'T KNOW.
>> WRAPPED UP BY TOMORROW?
>> NO, NO I THINK WE'VE GOT
PROGRESS.
WE'VE GOT A LITTLE MOVEMENT.
SO WE'LL SEE.
>> HAVE YOU HAD TO WALK BACK THE
THREATS YOU'LL STRIP COMMITTEE
ASSIGNMENTS.
>> I DIDN'T MAKE THAT.
>> MIKE ROGERS DID.
>> WELL, YOU'RE SAYING I MADE
THE THREAT.
LET'S BE VERY CLEAR.
I DID NOT MAKE THE THREAT.
AND, NO MEMBERS ARE NOT GOING TO
LOSE THEIR COMMITTEE
ASSIGNMENTS.
>> HOW LONG DO YOU THINK THIS
WILL DRAG OUT FOR AT THIS POINT?
>> I'D LOVE TO KNOW.
BUT WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS.
>> THIS IS THE LONGEST SINCE THE
1850s.
>> WELL, HAVE I THE LONGEST
SPEECH ON THE FLOOR.
SO APPARENTLY I LIKE TO MAKE
HISTORY.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED?
YOU'RE GIVING ONE MEMBER THE
POWER TO OUST YOU IF YOU'RE THE
SPEAKER.
>> THAT'S THE WAY IT'S ALWAYS
BEEN EXCEPT FOR THE LAST YEAR.
I THINK I'M FINE.
>> HAS IT CUT -- UNDERCUT THE
POWER OF ALL THE OTHER SPEAKERS?
>> BUT IT WAS USED OVER JOHN
BOEHNER.
>> I'M NOT --
>> SINCE 1850.
DOESN'T THAT INHERENTLY MEAN YOU
WOULD BE A WEAKER SPEAKER?
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT THERE
MIGHT BE FOUR WHO WILL JUST
NEVER VOTE FOR YOU AMONG THE
REPUBLICANS?
>> NO, I THINK WE'LL GET THERE.
>> DO YOU PLAN TO GOOD TO
CONFERENCE --
>> ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT LOSING
VOTES TO MODERATES IF YOU GIVE
TOO MUCH AWAY?
>> EVERYBODY IS INVOLVED IN IT.
WE'VE GOT TO GET THERE
COMPLETELY.
>> --
>> MR. McCARTHY --
>> CAN I FINISH HIS QUESTION?
THANKS.
A FIVE SEAT MAJORITY.
IT'S NOT ONE SIDE IS GOING TO
GET MORE THAN THE OTHER.
IT'S THE ENTIRE CONFERENCE IS
GOING TO HAVE TO LEARN HOW TO
WORK TOGETHER.
SO IT'S BETTER THAT WE GO
THROUGH THIS PROCESS RIGHT NOW
SO WE CAN ACHIEVE THE THINGS WE
WANT TO ACHIEVE FOR THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
WHAT OUR COMMITMENT WAS.
SO IF THIS TAKES A LITTLE LONGER
AND IT DOESN'T MEET YOUR
DEADLINE, THAT'S OKAY, BECAUSE
IT'S NOT -- IT'S NOT HOW YOU
START.
IT'S HOW YOU FINISH.
AND IF WE FINISH WELL, WE'LL BE
VERY SUCCESSFUL.
>> DO YOU PLAN TO GO CONFERENCE?
>> YOU'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
TWO MONTHS, THOUGH.
WHY WEREN'T THESE SORTED OUT
BEFORE JANUARY 3rd?
>> WELL, WE TRIED TO SORT IT
OUT.
>> DO YOU PLAN TO GO TO
CONFERENCE?
>> THANK YOU FOR STOPPING.
>> THAT LAST PART SAYING WE
TRIED TO SORT IT OUT BEFORE
JANUARY 3rd.
SO THEY HAVE BEEN TRYING THIS
FOR THE PAST TWO MONTHS, AND WE
ARE IN THIS POSITION NOW, EVEN
AS THEY'VE BEEN ENGAGED IN
FURIOUS NEGOTIATIONS, JAKE, ALL
DAY LONG, ALL AFTERNOON, ALL
NIGHT.
THEY STILL DO NOT HAVE A DEAL,
EVEN THOUGH THEY BELIEVE THEY
ARE GETTING CLOSER TO GETTING
SOME MORE REPUBLICANS SUPPORT
FOR KEVIN McCARTHY.
STILL WON'T BE ENOUGH TO GET
THEM TO 218.
BUT, JAKE, ALL SIGNS ARE
POINTING TO THIS WILL NOT BE
RESOLVED BY TOMORROW.
IT WILL ALMOST CERTAINLY BE
PUSHED INTO NEXT WEEK.
AND WITH KEVIN McCARTHY'S PATH
TO THE SPEAKERSHIP WILL REMAIN
AS NARROW AS EVER.
BUT AS YOU HEARD FROM HIM THERE,
HE STILL THINKS HE'LL GET THERE.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
INTERESTING, MANU, IS THAT THIS
ISN'T UNPRECEDENTED ENTIRELY.
IT HAS GONE TO MULTIPLE BALLOTS
BEFORE.
BUT THE LAST TIME IT HAPPENED
WAS LITERALLY 100 YEARS AGO.
AND THE LAST -- THERE HAVE ONLY
BEEN I THINK FIVE TIMES IN
HISTORY THAT IT'S GONE BEYOND 11
BALLOTS.
AND ALL FIVE OF THOSE TIMES WERE
BEFORE THE CIVIL WAR.
A NUMBER OF THEM RIGHT LEADING
UP.
WHEN THIS COUNTRY WAS MORE
DIVIDED THAN IT HAS EVER BEEN
UNTIL POSSIBLY NOW, ALTHOUGH YOU
CAN MAKE THE ARGUMENT CERTAINLY
IT WAS MUCH WORSE BACK THEN.
BUT I WONDER IF THIS IS
INDICATIVE OF THESE TREMENDOUS
DIVISIONS.
BACK THEN THERE WERE -- THIS IS
BEFORE THE MAJOR TWO-PARTY
SYSTEM.
THERE WERE DEMOCRATS, DEMOCRATIC
REPUBLICANS, THERE WERE WHIGS,
ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
THE DIVISIONS WITHIN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY ARE SO VICIOUS
RIGHT NOW.
>> AND THEY HAVE BEEN BUILDING
AND BUILDING FOR YEARS.
REALLY EVER SINCE 2010, THE
START OF THE TEA PARTY MOVEMENT.
AND THAT REALLY SAW THE MORE
TYPICAL MIDDLE OF THE ROAD
ESTABLISHMENT-MINDED
REPUBLICANS, BUSINESS FRIENDED
REPUBLICANS BE PIT UP AGAINST
MORE A MOVEMENT CONSERVATIVES,
MR. OF THE FAR RIGHT
CONSERVATIVES WHO WERE USHERED
INTO POWER IN THE 2010 ELECTION.
ULTIMATELY, LEADING TO THE
OUSTER OF JOHN BOEHNER AS
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE IN 2015.
THAT TEA PARTY FACTION, THAT
HARD RIGHT GROUP THAT
ENCOMPASSES THE HOUSE REEMD
CAUCUS, THEY'RE THE ONES WHO ARE
THREATENING TO USE THE POWER TO
PUSH FOR JOHN BOEHNER TO BE
OUSTED FROM THE SPEAKERSHIP, LED
JOHN BOEHNER TO STEP ASIDE.
ULTIMATELY LEADING TO PAUL RYAN
TO BECOME SPEAKER, KEVIN
McCARTHY.
DIDN'T HAVE THE VOTES TO BECOME
SPEAKER THEN.
AND NOW IT'S BUILT UP DURING THE
TRUMP YEARS TO WHERE WE'RE
SEEING THIS SERIOUS DIVIDE
BETWEEN THE FAR RIGHT AND THE
MORE ESTABLISHMENT-MINDED
MEMBERS OF HIS CONFERENCE.
BUT JAKE, THAT IS THE REAL
CONCERN FOR McCARTHY GOING
FORWARD AFTER THIS.
BECAUSE OF THAT CONCESSION THAT
HE HAS MADE, GIVING ONE MEMBER
THE POWER TO CALL FOR A VOTE TO
OUST A SITTING SPEAKER, HE IS
GOING TO GO BACK TO THE RULES
THAT JOHN BOEHNER HAD THAT LED
TO BOEHNER'S OUSTER.
YOU HEARD HIM THERE WHEN I ASKED
ABOUT THE CONCERN.
HE SAID I AM NOT AFRAID OF THAT.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE A WEAKER
SPEAKER.
SO HE HAS CLAIMS HE IS FINE WITH
THIS.
BUT IT COULD VERY WELL MEAN HE
COULD HAVE A SHORT-LIVED
SPEAKERSHIP IF HE EVEN GETS
THERE, JAKE.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
ONE OF THOSE PRECIVIL WAR
MULTIPLE BALLOT SPEAKERSHIP
DEADLOCKS, THE GUY THAT WON,